a lot of guys futures
that are
you know uncertain you know myself
included
uh
that's what's sad about it most
so how do you go on from here i mean you
can just hit on some of the realities
and then they go so how do you go on
from here how do you how do you take the
next step
yeah bill that's a good question i don't
know i really don't uh
there's a lot of unknowns going into
this offseason now
and
they just i'm gonna have to take some
time away for sure and
clear my head and
just kind of see what's going on with
everything
but it's uh
it's pretty tough right now
you know back when the packers traded up
to draft quarterback jordan love
in april
in the aftermath of that there was a lot
of speculation how much longer would
aaron rodgers be with the team how is
this going to end it's not going to end
well he had brett favre acting as kind
of a surrogate to the media because he
spoke to farv and then farve did
different radio shows saying that aaron
should be upset and disrespected and and
then it all died down when the season
came along and everything was great
everything was fine he played better
than ever he had an mvp season and
that's what made yesterday's comments
that came out of the blue unprompted
nobody asked him a single question about
his future with the team how much longer
he's going to play with the packers it
all was something he brought up when he
veered into the line a lot of guys
futures are uncertain
myself included
and then he had the longer answer about
taking some time to
think things through
i started seeing tweets from people who
have covered the packers for years who
were interpreting in the moment the
comments of aaron rodgers is some sort
of a farewell that was stunning to me
that's the last thing i thought we'd be
talking about coming out of that game i
thought this season showed us this guy's
all in and he's going to be all in next
year and he's going to be all in the
year after that and
jordan love is going to become jimmy
garoppolo and he's going to get traded
in his fourth season and this is just
the thing that kickstarts the second act
of aaron rodgers just like jimmy g kick
started the second act of tom brady
that's what made yesterday's comments so
stunning to me because they came so far
at a left field they cut against
everything that we had believed as the
season unfolded and now here we are back
where we were in april how much longer
is he going to play for the packers yeah
well i mean
everything you said is right there i
mean yeah he's all in mvp all that
this is the problem though here's the
problem you just said it perfectly mike
you're right he's all in mvp year but
you know what the team's not all in on
him they're not
i don't even know what to say they're
not i mean how long are you gonna abuse
the guy and just ask him to carry the
team i mean there we are it's
championship sunday oh the quarterback
with the least amount of weapons is ding
ding ding aaron rodgers once again in
championship sunday all the other
quarterbacks got top tier weapons
everywhere aaron rodgers got devonte
adams yes who's good you're really good
there's no doubt he ain't tyree top ten
he's not tyree kill i ain't mike evans i
don't think he's on their level of those
guys but either way i
that's where he's gotta feel and how can
he not feel devastated yeah he's
devastated yes he's got to watch the guy
that always goes to the super bowl go to
the super bowl and he got to watch him
play in a game where he went man he
didn't even play good and he's going to
win i played really good i threw a
strike and it was past interference and
it got intercepted and that was the only
mistake i made all game long
and we had a drop touchdown by devonte
adams and all those he's he's got to be
as devastated as an athlete as i you can
ever be around right now he has to be
nobody has done more for an organization
in their history of my lifetime to this
point and the return favor is nothing
back always and for aaron rodgers and
he's he's i'm sure it was wit's end
right now mike
well and one aspect to it which we
discussed last hour carius carius carius
carius until it's fourth and goal from
the eighth season on the line
we'll kick the field goal and ride our
defense we don't need you to carry us in
this moment which is a little bit of a
twist of the knife at that point like
you want me to carry you i've led us
back from this deficit you're not gonna
let me finish the job are you kidding me
so i think that's percolating around in
there too but you know there's two ways
to interpret what he said yesterday and
the naysayers and it's amazing to me how
many people in this business don't want
to be bothered with a potentially juicy
and interesting story that will drive
legitimate interest this isn't clickbait
this is real bait he put it out there he
put it out there for all of us to notice
so either he gave into the emotion of
the moment and had no forethought
whatsoever to what he said
or
and and i'm gonna go with the or because
he's a smart guy
he knew there was a chance they were
going to lose he knew there was no
guarantee that that was a victory he
knew he was going to be meeting with the
media he surely has thought through
every angle about what his future could
be would be should be next year if they
lost that game yesterday and for him to
throw out there that his future's
uncertain you know when he addressed the
issue of his future last week and said
it's a beautiful mystery he was
addressing it from the context of the
team like maybe the team won't want him
which was just kind of weird it's like
come on aaron
have you have you not looked at your
stats this year have you not watched any
of your film they watch you next year
yesterday it flipped for me chris over
to
does he want yeah to be
there right and and it's amazing how
many people
have failed to notice that football has
changed you just don't slam the door in
the guy's face when he's a franchise
quarterback who doesn't want to be there
anymore we've spent the last three weeks
talking about desean watson matthew
stafford's getting out of detroit ben
roethlisberger may work his way out of
pittsburgh if that's what he chooses to
do it's still way too early to know what
he wants to do
but
aaron rodgers
he told us yesterday with his words that
this is in play he hasn't made the
decision yet
but it's in play
yeah i mean listen he's speaking from a
point of just
total gut-wrenching defeat
his soul is crying i mean so we got to
be careful about reading too deep into
to any of this there's nobody said it
but he did say it and he's very smart
and he does realize what he's saying i
don't deny that at all mike i'm with you
there and it's something that i'm sure
he's thought about in depth way before
this comment or before this so he's a
he's a deep guy we know i mean most
people we talk to tell you like hey
roger's one of those guys that's like he
walks in the room he's it's he's the
smartest guy in the room you know other
than maybe a few special rooms here and
there
but i he's just got to be beaten down
by
the constant well aaron rodgers can't do
it oh aaron rodgers you know you can oh
he's never been to another super bowl
he's only been to one when it's just the
exact opposite it's just the team
constantly letting him down whether it's
letting a guy just run a go route before
halftime or not going forward on fourth
down or the running back fumbled in an
easy catch over the middle to start the
half you know we can go through history
too and i can start to lay out moments
where the team you know
doesn't help him out
and you know even lafleur's comments
about you know who was over the top you
know praising rogers i i hope he doesn't
leave he's the heart and soul of our
football team and all that you know yes
but see that's the problem too that's
the problem in green bay there is
nothing there's no culture
it's always been just about one guy it's
always been here's brett favre and
here's aaron rodgers and if they play
awesome today they're a hundred percent
game then we can beat you but if they
play a 99
whoa we don't know what the hell's gonna
happen and that's really what they
that's what they've done in green bay
like yesterday mike you watch that game
who on green bay is a leader or has
attitude who i see tampa bay players
going crazy foaming at the mouth devin
white levante david shaquille barrett
people are yelling showing emotion green
bay it's all like um
um i hope aaron bails us out um
i hope he bails us out one more time
please i mean it's just it's that's the
culture up there and that's why they
can't get over the hump and get to a
super bowl or win it
but he's part of it and he's stayed part
of it over the past 12 years he doesn't
know any different
well
but but but he's smart enough to see
what other quarterbacks are doing and
maybe that's what he's thinking he sees
what tom brady did
jumping from a team that didn't have the
help around him yeah to a team that does
and what a difference a year makes and
we'll give him the benefit of
him being a genius he's smart enough to
think these things through and look one
of the reasons that that i i respect him
so much and i've said this before i
think he and i have a lot more in common
than we do oh you're not in common and
that may be one of the reasons why
we bought heads but
you know i i can't fault him
for
reacting the way he did feeling the way
he felt right when they have a
first-round pick in a receiver-rich
draft
and they need receivers receiver rich
draft first-round pick they trade up oh
we getting a receiver now we're getting
another quarterback well maybe we'll get
a receiver with the second round pick no
no we're not going through the third
round pick no no we're not going to do
that fourth round pick oh wait we use
that to trade up to get the quarterback
the the not drafting any receivers at
all last year just felt like a middle
finger to him i mean it was just weird
it was awkward and again i credit him
and i can't help but wonder let me
psychoanalyze a little bit because again
i think i have a lot of common with him
although i'll submit that he's probably
50 iq points higher than me
i can understand what what he
was thinking going into the season yeah
nothing is going to
be gained from being pissy all the time
sorry london having an attitude being
mad acting out
he made a deal with himself i believe to
be the consummate teammate the
consummate soldier he's going to do
everything that's asked of him he's
going all in and he's getting through
this season and then after the season
he's going to take a step back and ask
himself is this where i want to be
what have they done to make me think i
want to be here right they are grooming
my replacement am i going to walk before
they run me out of here and remember he
was there to see what they did to brett
favre and make no mistake about it they
went to brett favre in february 2008 and
said we need to know right now what
you're going to do next season we didn't
know right now right now tell us right
now because they knew the answer would
be well if i have to tell you right now
i'm retired and then they slam the door
they barricade it with furniture they
draft seven quarterbacks not seven but
two on top of aaron rodgers and then
they just hoped brett favre wouldn't
show up again and then it was awkward
and it was ugly and it was a bad divorce
and i i he saw that in an early stage of
his career he saw how it can fall apart
and i think he's decided
i'm not going to sit back and let it
happen yeah i have a bet
i'm going to take the initiative here
and i think yesterday's comments may
have been the first step down that path
i i agree with that mike i do you know
one he's seen brady seen peyton manning
do it right both guys left went to
better teams had better supporting casts
and you know did some special things in
their career in their second spots i
mean brady's is not over yet this is
only year one in the new team so i'm
sure he looks at that and that gives
that's gonna give any quarterback like
in these situations confidence going
forward
there's no doubt about that and then you
know
yeah listen
we know
okay aaron rodgers the starting
quarterback this year for the green bay
packers
but i think what he's trying to say too
is like listen they did draft a
quarterback i mean we're coming down to
things are the uncertain time it's one
of these next year or two and they're
gonna have to start thinking about
something so yeah it is uncertain
because at the very most it's two years
from now all right so rogers and a year
in advance is gonna start thinking like
you said maybe i should control how this
goes a little bit and maybe i need to
get out a year early or just see where
it goes or either way i don't expect
that to happen but i expect him to take
a little time take a deep breath and you
know you might you said it mike i mean
it's disrespectful that they didn't get
any i know they're in the nfc
championship game
anybody who would tell you there's a big
difference between getting to the nfc
championship game
and being a super bowl winner there's a
huge difference in your football team in
that aspect you've heard that a million
times from coaches all that they did
nothing to help this team out this year
nothing really okay yeah aj dillon had
three carries yesterday that was the
contribution from last year's draft in
that game thank you thank you i mean
even defenders pass rushers anything
would have made him probably feel a
little bit better to go wait at least
that'll help our defense and contribute
but instead it's the second year in a
row
we leave an nfc championship game where
they were bullied out physical
and
you know it's just too much relying on
one guy to win football games and that's
just not going to get it done in the
ultimate team sport
and what's so weird about last year his
press conference afterward we ran a link
to it in a story we posted last night he
was upbeat he was positive he said this
is the year that football became fun
again and we're gonna get one of these
sooner rather than later that was
pre-jordan love he went into the
off-season with a very bright and
positive and optimistic viewpoint about
the things they could do to improve
their team to close the gap between
themselves and the 49ers and what did
they do they invested two picks of one
and a four
in his replacement so
how do you not feel slighted by that if
you're aaron rodgers i credit him for
internalizing it i credit him for
turning it into a positive i credit him
for having one of the best quarterback
seasons we've ever seen but now it's
over and now we're back to where we were
and he's got to decide just like you
said am i going to let this play out
the way they want it to or am i going to
make it play out the way
i want it to
and that's why we need to watch and wait
and see what happens you made another
point too about the packers you know
i've had this take about the vikings
that they're they're content to be just
good enough they're content to be nine
and seven ten and six make it to
playoffs every other year exit quickly
whatever
the packers arguably are content to be
just great enough seems like it not not
super bowl winner but hey well we go to
the nfc championship game well so what
one of these years you got to get to a
super bowl and win it i don't know
whether this traces back to the absence
of a single owner yes who can hold
people accountable every day every day
every day yeah there's something there
that's keeping them from being what they
can be especially with one of the great
quarterbacks of all time on the right i
mean i i agree and i think any real like
real list like mike again green bay has
done so many good things
they're they're a top-notch organization
and i know we're being negative on them
right now and i'm probably extra
negative because i love aaron rodgers
and i feel like he's been cheated so
sorry you have to deal with that
personal aspect of it but i i
i yes because i feel like an owner one
is going to push the team over to make
aggressive decisions and then also push
them over to go wait what what we're
going to draft a quarterback our
quarterback's still one of the three or
four best in the game what are we doing
or the owner is going to go wait we got
this quarterback we need to get all
these players and receivers around him
and and really accentuate what he has
that's when the owner does come in handy
he realizes like whoa i got a big shiny
diamond here i know diamonds i'm a
billionaire so let me start getting some
you know nice gold settings and platinum
settings around it to make it look
pretty that's one thing i know they can
do and that's where it's just doesn't
seem to ever happen in green bay
and
what what you will hear from those in
the media who would just not be bothered
with this storyline even though it's
been dropped into our laps by aaron
rodgers you will hear they won't trade
him and they can't trade him because
trading him would trigger a 31 million
cap charge and i got a couple of points
to make about that yeah
first first
trading him
would and and you can see the whole
story at pft where i break it all down
but here are the highlights if you trade
him you're taking a 31 and a half
million dollar cap charge this year
if you keep him you're taking a 37 and a
half million dollar cap charge this year
so he actually saves 6 million in cap
space right and 23 million or so in cash
by trading so
it's it's not a crippling cap hit
because if anything you have to do more
work to put a team on the field if you
have aaron rodgers and you're paying him
his 23 million dollar compensation
package secondly and i think this is the
thing this is the moment where i had the
eureka this is where the light bulb went
on for me last night as i was thinking
this through
you can trade him after june 1. and if
you trade him after june 1 the cap
charge for this year is 14.3 million and
you push the rest of it to next year
when the pandemic won't have kept the
numbers down the salary caps going to be
180. we can take a 14 million cap charge
this year and people say oh they can't
trade him june 2. everybody has their
quarterbacks by then they have their off
season program folks do you really think
there's gonna be an off-season program
do do you really think there's gonna be
one when they've already they've already
canceled the scouting combine do you
think there's gonna be an off-season
program this year do you think aaron
rodgers is gonna miss anything so what
you do chris we see it all the time now
before the start of the league year
teams work out trades and when do they
do them not that day they can't they do
it the first day of the league year
right so if a trade's going to happen
and again it's a big if but but i'm just
saying don't just dismiss it out of hand
like oh never do it you work it out in
march and you do it on june 2nd yeah
when the cap hit would only be 14
million dollars instead of 31. there's
an easy way to do this if you decide if
you're the packers and and please spare
me the idea that this is something the
packers would want to do this isn't a
packers motivated decision this is
rogers exactly part owner of the
milwaukee bucks acting like an nba
player yeah no i and that's really what
what to watch for here you know like you
said
all those things you laid out
exactly right
the big thing is is it's
if rogers doesn't want to play there
anymore and then then he doesn't want to
play there anymore there's the green
belly's going to be in a tough spot you
know and again we've talked about this
like with deshaun watson man when you
have a franchise quarterback in a locker
room and he ain't happy and he's the
best player in your team and he's not
happy and now he's talking crap about
the gm and the coaches and how crappy
this place is watch your team play like
crap on sundays and fall apart during
the season that always what will will
happen i don't know if he's willing to
go that far but either way i think it's
safe to say sitting here monday after a
championship sunday that rogers is
pissed off he's hurt and everything has
kind of come to this you know pinnacle
right now of feeling cheated and mad and
everything about what's going on in
green bay
let's
to to put any question to rest is where
the packers are coming from let's hear
from matt leflore after the game
regarding this possibility as brought up
by rogers that he may not be back next
year
i sure as hell hope so
i mean
guys
the mvp of this league
he is
the heart and soul of our football team
so hell yeah
he better be back here
um
he's our leader
and you know
just so appreciative of
him buying into what we're trying to get
done around here and and leading that
group
yeah i mean they want him back without
question they want to be able to decide
when to move on from him that's the key
right they want to continue to hold all
the cards they don't want him grabbing
the cards out of their hands and saying
we're going to do it my way it's that
simple and you know what here's another
thing to not rule out chris yeah i know
it may sound i know it may sound a
little goofy but that's okay it's never
stopped me in the past
he's going to be a guest host on
jeopardy and the full list of guest
hosts is out katie couric bill whitaker
from 60 minutes
mayan bialik from the
big bang theory show and i think she's
on another show now and aaron rodgers
that's it now if this is some
sort of group of finalists or whatever i
don't know they're going to be guestos
for jeopardy i think at some level he
thinks he's got the chops to do it and
maybe he does and maybe he just says see
you later i'm done i'm out i'm just
gonna retire the door's open for me to
host jeopardy and i'm gonna go do it i
mean we can't rule that side of it out
either well i i mean you're right but i
just i don't see that with him this
level of play still
you know arguably still towards the top
of football i just think it'll be hard
and i still think you know he he's like
we've talked about mike he just he's
very in reality and understands the
conversation around him and i think he's
going to go down trying to win one more
super bowl i don't think he's ready to
give up that fight uh at least not yet
and last thing mike just with the
lefleur comments
you know lafleur you could tell he
really likes aaron rodgers with that
comment right there i mean you could
tell
he's basically saying listen we're not
here if we don't have that guy he's the
heart and soul of our football team
everything they do is predicated through
him and what he does on the field how he
leads guys off the field all those
things you know i still don't know i
don't know this for sure but i don't
think lefleur was in on wanting to draft
the jordan love quarterback thing and
get in this situation anyways i've been
led to believe that by a lot of people
in the league so
he i think he's in a situation where
he's literally saying like man i didn't
do this i love you you're the man no you
need to come back you're the heart and
soul of the team i mean he looked like
he was getting emotional and almost
going to cry there a little bit because
i think he understands too the broad
picture that surrounds aaron rodgers and
then it's not fair that people talk
about him as oh yeah you can't win the
championship game and all that stuff
between him deshawn watson matthew
stafford possibility of ben
roethlisberger moving on to another team
although i think it's slim this
offseason is going to be chock full of
quarterback story lines and and again
i would have never brought this up today
it never would have been an issue if he
didn't say what he said yesterday and if
it wasn't accompanied by observations
from people who have been covering that
team for years that it felt like the
beginning of a goodbye from aaron
rodgers which was stunning to me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports